Speaker 1: Let's start with something a little
different today. I kind of like this quite a bit.
Byron Donalds and Jamaal Bowman are two members
of Congress. Byron Donalds is a Republican from
Florida. Jamaal Bowman is a Democrat representing
New York. They had a debate of sorts on the steps
of the Capitol in Washington, D.C. and it
is cartoonish in a way. There's not like
deep policy substance here. But I would much
prefer this debate to what we've seen recently
in terms of our elected officials engaging in.
So let's take a look at this. This happening on
the steps of the Capitol in DC. You will see
Byron Donalds on on the left of the screen,
and then Jamaal Bowman will pop up
and be on the right of the screen.
Speaker 2: What I will say first with
the gentleman from New York is, Oh,
I want everybody get this done. The gentleman
said in general to the gentleman from New York,
man, listen, it's cool. I have two people in my
state that could be president. I don't know about
New York. I'm just going to say no. As always,
Thank you, President Hu. The city's more man
sentences man. 40, 45 minutes. He's an asshole as
he's a white supremacist now. He's anti-gay. He's
in trouble. No, listen, there's no way he can be
president for my colleagues in the legislature.
The other one who's a Democrat. When all that
stuff was coming last year, I called them. I said,
Tell me what's happening. They were like, It's
really not that. But people are trying to raise
a fuss. I've had the conversations. It's not
true. I had the conversation of why can't those
who have been incarcerated, who are released,
who have done their time, why can't they be re
enfranchised and be allowed to vote? They are
in our state, so we're not going anywhere. You
voted for the bill tomorrow. I was there when I
was the second guy. Who's the second guy? Second
person second. Come on. Now, you already know
that Trump and Ron Trump. It's true for people. So
Trump claims Florida. Now he claim New York.
They claim Florida two years. Now they claim.
That's what you said. Boston. They said. That's
what he said to Kathy. Oh, he told Kathy Hochul.
They said, I got to go. Both those two is going
to get crushed. Stop the man at 1600. Gretchen,
please. If she wanted to jump in, she would kill
both of them. Secondly, Biden will kill both of
them by the past three days in person.
Speaker 1: This is arguably the
best part here. Coming up.
Speaker 2: We bypass you. You
know what that's like? You know what that's like
by saying Josh Allen is better than Patrick. But
I didn't come on through somebody else. I didn't
pass three bipartisan pieces of legislation
after an insurrection during a global pandemic
opened back up the spoils of your game. On the
inside. He is all about the infrastructure
bill. That's all we talk about. Sanders
ain't even mention the bills. What are we talking
about? We will wipe the floor with the scientists.
And what world come? And what world was all
the land chips at? Stop Infrastructure Bill.
If a community that is talking beside me,
$35 insulin pie inflation over on southern
border and everybody's free, we can do the same
thing. I could do the same thing. What's he got?
Speaker 1: All right, So. So listen.
What what did we learn? Right?
Only one person there was actually armed with
facts. Okay. That's the reality. It was Jamaal
Bowman. But they were at least relatively more
substantive discussions than Jewish space lasers,
woke masks, trans, whatever the case may be. Now,
this was not a debate in the sense that you can't
really debate with someone who's simply refusing
to acknowledge basic facts. You can't. And Donald
is, of course, complicit in the hate and the anger
that is driving Republican voters to do what they
do. And that's all very sad. So I'm not saying,
oh to good faith participants in whatever fight,
but notice that. Whenever policy accomplishments
are brought up there by Jamaal Bowman.
Byron Donalds can say nothing but no. Stop, stop,
No. When Bowman cites actual Biden accomplishments
and this is what the right has, they have in their
worst cases, right? Like Marjorie Taylor GREENE.
They have that completely unhinged rhetoric
in the best cases where it's sort of congenial
and generally speaking, respectful as this
was. They still have nothing more on policy,
and that's extraordinarily telling. And then,
of course, the fact that Byron Donalds thinks
we have we have such rich. We have a richness
of candidates in Florida. We've got Trump
and we've got the Santas. Now, I don't know that
I share Bowman's confidence that Biden would wipe
the floor with DeSantis. That remains to be
seen. But if more of the conversations among
our elected officials were like this, I mean,
I'd rather than be more like the Lincoln-Douglas
debates. But that ship seems to have sailed a
couple of hundred years ago. If there were more
like this than what we normally get, I actually
would prefer it. Let me know what you think.